les armes chimiques ont atteint une
efficacité effroyable en voici une
démonstration une goutte de l'eau des
plus récents gaz de combat toxiques
nerveux va tomber près de ce lapin dans
les secondes qui suivent
l'animal s'agite et pris de convulsions
c'est tout deux minutes et demie plus
tard il meurt un soldat du subi le même
sort 15 à 30% des munitions dans
l'arsenal des grandes puissances sont
chimiques
mais après avoir déversé
125 mille tonnes de produits toxiques
durant la première guerre mondiale et
fait un million et demi de victimes
les gaz n'ont pas été employés au cours
de la seconde guerre mondiale d'armes
d'emplois ils sont devenus des armes de
dissuasion
on s'est alors intéressé aux drogues non
mortels capable de mettre les individus
hors d'état de se défendre voici les
faits de drogue hallucinogène analogue
au lsd le ch a drogué perd toute
agressivité craint la souris il semble
que de telles armes auraient été essayée
au vietnam mais qu'on y aurait renoncé
car les effets sont imprévisibles dans
tous les arsenaux on cherche le gaz
susceptible de paralyser temporairement
ou d'endormir les individus mais aucun
ne semble parfaitement au point les
états majors se sont alors intéressés à
des munitions plus redoutable que les
poissons les microbes voici au centre
britannique de porter des recherches sur
l' arme biologique
ces travaux sont entourés de précaution
extraordinaire il il ya quelques années
un chercheur de ce centre est mort de la
peste le bacille le virus c'est
théoriquement larmes absolue larmes qui
se propage se multiplient chez l'ennemi
un foyers localisés déclenché une
épidémie général
il ne faudrait que 500 grammes de toxine
botulique pour exterminer la population
du club
mais ces armes sont heureusement très
difficile à mettre en oeuvre les
microbes ne se laisse pas mobilisé les
anti médecins étudient des centaines de
culture microbienne multiplie les
expériences sacrifices innombrables
cobaye pour trouver les microbes parfait
à celui ci il demanderait d'être porteur
d'une maladie rapidement mortelle de se
propager très aisément de se conserver
facilement de se répandre les
populations amis devraient être vaccinés
mais aucun remède ne devrait protéger
les populations vis et il semble
qu'aucune des 160 maladies infectieuses
connu ne réponde à ces spécifications de
pochoirs mais on sait aujourd'hui
manipuler l'appli provoquer une mutation
créer de nouvelles espèces l'homme tente
de fabriquer artificiellement larmes
biologique absolue que la nature n'a pas
inventé en dépit de la peste du choléra
du typhus et d autres maladies